JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hi, I'm Jake
Archibald, and I love the web.
It's the safest
platform in the world,
and there's absolutely
no barrier to entry.
You just visit a URL
and you get content.
So let's have a discussion
on how we might screw that
all up with installable
apps and missions.
First introduced this subject,
it Mozilla's very own, Marcos
Caceres.
So do you want to get your
laptop plugged in and start--
MARCOS CACERES: I'm up?
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
--making words happen.
Go for it.
MARCOS CACERES: All right.
Fantastic.
So thanks very much
for the [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not going to talk about me.
But I work for Mozilla
and I'm extremely
interested in this area.
I've been looking at it
for a very, very long time.
Installable web apps and
permissions-- the problem first
up is that these are
very related topics
but they're actually
different topics.
So I actually want to talk
about them separately.
When we think about permissions
and with the discussions
that we've been having within
the community, to some degree
we're talking about this right?
Is this actually
just a straw man?
Or is this actually
a real problem?
Is this actually happening?
Is this something people
are experiencing and why?
So I'm just going to rush.
I only have 10
minutes so I'm going
to rush through all this stuff.
We do have models on the
web for when we introduce
new APIs about how
we make a decision,
whether we want an API or not.
So Adrian [INAUDIBLE]
has a nice diagram.
I'm sorry it's going to be
extremely difficult for you
guys to read it, if you
want to see it online.
But it essentially has
very simple decisions
where you can say, for instance,
can the action be undone?
Can the action be undone with
minimal effort, yes or no?
If it's yes, then
automatic grant.
If it's now, you
ask another question
about the severity and so on.
And from that you can
basically create an API
and decide on their permission
level that you want to give it.
Then we have a
different model which
is, for instance, with service
workers and request total
complete, where--
don't get excited.
And that model is like--
you have an SSL certificate,
and if you do then you
can access this API.
So I'm not saying these are
good things or bad things?
Do we need these things?
Is this enough?
So this is for the panel.
Is that what we need?
Why are we getting stuck?
We know-- you know, for
instance, for geolocation,
we're kind of stuck
because we can't really no
if the permission's been
granted before we actually
make the request.
And that's screwing us.
Like when we try
to develop sites,
that's screwing us,
because we don't
know what's happening there.
So we need to fix
those kinds of things.
So it's 2014, where are my apps?
Why can't I install yet?
What the hell's going on?
It's interesting-- the
problem is of installation,
because it's not
just like, can we
add the apps to the home screen.
In the sidelines,
those are going on.
You know there's this
whole package apps movement
and also there's hybrid apps.
So let's start with
web apps, very quickly.
Are we installable yet?
Do we have the right bits
that we actually need?
So I'm treating model
view controllers
as HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript as the kind
of embodiment all
these concepts.
Are we there with that stuff?
Kind of.
If I had to give a rating to
this I would maybe give it,
like, a C plus.
We can do a lot of really
cool stuff on the web
but some stuff is
really challenging.
You're going to hear more of
this throughout this today.
We don't have a really
good design language yet
to express apps on the web.
Giving apps a name--
a very simple thing.
That's not really
well supported.
So we have title elements but we
don't really have a short name,
like you do in iOS.
Icons is just really bad
on the web right now.
We need to really work on icons.
Display modes-- full
screen, fantastic.
Are there other
display modes than we
should be looking at
for installable apps?
Orientation is really
bad at the moment.
We're working on fixing that.
We don't really have control
orientation right now
to lock orientation.
Offline-- we've all heard
Jake, blab, blab, blab.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well done.
MARCOS CACERES: Yeah, well done.
But today, man, it's bad.
You know?
I would give it a D
or an F, you know?
A start page for an app.
The place that you first go.
We don't have that concept.
So you go to a page,
you go to an app.
You leave, you come back, and
you're like at the same place.
That might be good,
that might be bad.
When you install
an app, usually you
want a place to go
where you start from.
So I'm really trying
to rush these.
Navigational
boundaries-- so when
you install an app
like a native app,
it has a starting point
and an ending point.
And you know when you jump
from one app to the other.
On the web, there
isn't that concept.
We don't have a
concept of boundaries.
You follow links, and if
those links look the same,
essentially in the same app--
you can be at Google.com
and bounce from one
app to the other
and you wouldn't even
know where you are.
So the only cues that
we have are visual cues.
In native apps you actually
have actual boundaries.
They'll call them physical
boundaries that prevent you
from going from one
place to another.
And the visual cues
are very evident.
And they're not
there on the web,
or at least in the
installable web,
particularly people who've
tried to build for iOS.
You've probably seen that.
If you try to navigate,
it stops for navigating,
so you have to hijack
navigation and so on.
So I've talking five minutes.
Capabilities-- an
integration into the system.
Device APIs-- can web apps use,
let's say, iOS's health kit?
What about all the fip
bits and things that?
What's going on?
Why can't we do that?
How do we get there?
And that integration
into the OS, into to task
switch and so on.
Again I'm going to call out iOS.
You've seen that it
doesn't really work.
Like, if you're at the home
screen, a website on iOS,
and you double-tap,
the screen goes black.
It doesn't remember
anything if you leave.
But at the same time they've
done really nice work.
So if you like
enable geolocation
it will actually be
in the privacy section
with all the other apps,
which is kind of cool.
So there's potential there.
Meanwhile, single page
apps, we've all seen 'em.
They were introduced
in iOS back in 2009.
I did a little study
of what's going.
I looked at the
top 78,000 sites.
I found 1,000, nearly
1,100 that were
claiming to be installable apps.
What I actually found was
that 90% of those apps cannot
actually be used as standalone.
This also in October
of last year.
Of the 10% that we're actually
usable, as installable apps,
28% had significant limitations
that didn't actually
allow to use those apps.
85% of the sites
relied on hyperlinks,
which meant that the whole
process of installing the app
was basically just facade.
I won't go through
the other details
but the story is kind of bad.
We need to really fix this.
Meanwhile we have packaged apps.
You know, they solve
offline for us.
Firefox OS is using
them extensively,
but they lead to proprietary
app stores, which is not great,
doesn't scale.
It's not really web friendly.
And it forces
centralized control
because you need to have a
digital signature in order
to these things.
Again, not great.
But it's not the
web, as people say,
because you cannot really
link to them either.
So we should really
talk about that.
And then we have the hybrid app.
So the hybrid app is
an interesting beast.
BRIAN LEROUX: Seriously?
MARCOS CACERES: I actually
wanted to find a beautiful--
because a hybrid app--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You failed.
MARCOS CACERES: I did.
I wanted to introduce
it with that,
but-- you know, the hybrid app--
I find it really interesting.
And particularly in iOS8.
Again, you know, I'm a
little bit obsessed with iOS
because they've made
it really, really
easy to take a web
view, like with Swift,
and you can just embed it,
and you can inject JavaScript.
You can write your
own APIs that talk
through a very
simple communication
channel between Swift or
Objective C and JavaScript.
This is like, for me, this
is like super, crazy cool.
And PhoneGaps has been
doing this for ages.
You guys have worked
this out ages ago.
But the interesting thing
is-- so you get this deep OS
integration in clearing
the permissioning,
but you also get this
ability to, like-- you know,
forget Windows, I'm just going
to focus on whatever system.
And I'm just going to
build plugins for that.
And this pluggable model that
leverages the web and the OS?
I think that battle
is going to heat up.
And I think if it's
only going to be closed,
proprietary platforms, they're
going to have a problem.
So discuss, basically.
That's like, in 10
minutes, the world.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Thank you very much.
MARCOS CACERES: No problem.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, so to
field questions on that subject
we have Marcos who you've
already met from Mozilla.
We also have Eli
Fidler, who works
on the browser and we
platform for BlackBerry.
We have Matt Andrews, who's done
work with the FT and Economist
web apps, and has done lots
of exciting stuff with offline
first, on the web.
We've got Chris Wilson.
One of my colleagues at Chrome.
Do think it's fair to say
we're Chromatically involved?
CHRIS WILSON: Of course.
As long as you're comfortable
letting people know that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
Chris is working
on making the a
first class platform.
And Brian Leroux, a
pioneer in dragging the web
onto the mobile world via
PhoneGap here at Adobe.
So please do be part
of the discussion.
Please jump in using On Slide.
It doesn't have to
be a question either.
You could be making a statement.
Yeah, please, be part
of the discussion.
So, OK, panel, get
yourselves into the
receive position for
the first question which
comes from Sara F. And so
I'll paraphrase it here.
Recently the Verge announced
that they are discontinuing
their device specific
apps in favor
of a truly responsive site.
Is that trend we should
expect to continue,
and why isn't every
app doing this?
So, Matt, you've done
stuff on the web.
And it works, right?
So we've won?
Yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
MATT ANDREWS: I wish
it was that simple.
I hope that continues.
That's what we've done.
That's what the Economist
is also moving towards.
Yeah.
I think there's still, as Marcos
showed, huge holes in the web
platform that make that
very difficult right now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what
troubles did you have?
MATT ANDREWS: I think the
offline, F minus, or whatever
that got, is probably the
biggest problem, at least
for us.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
Brain you've kind of
straddled both worlds
of web and native.
Do we even still
have to do that?
It's done, right?
BRIAN LEROUX: I wish it was.
I think it depends
on your app content
and what you're
trying to do, what
you're trying to achieve
with that content.
If you've got something
that's more text heavy
and needs to be updated
frequently then responsive
websites make a lot of sense.
As soon as you start
having interactivity
that involves the
sensors of the phone,
the web's kind of a ghetto.
And then if you need
that thing to be offline,
you well know that
that can be difficult.
The trick is,
though, people always
say that native's
better at offline.
I don't think that's true.
Like this morning I was trying
to get into Uber and I'm with
T-Mobile so I couldn't.
Because effectively I was
offline even I said it was on.
[LAUGHTER]
And Uber works really poorly
when you're not online.
And that's the case
with a lot of apps.
So I don't know that offline
is actually a native advantage,
it's just a programming style.
And the web style just
happens to be really hostile.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And working
with the offline stuff,
I find that it's only the
very best of native apps
that seem to do this stuff
well, very few of them.
So what kind of stuff
do you see people
using PhoneGap for today?
BRIAN LEROUX: They us if
for all kinds of stuff
they probably
shouldn't use it for.
And they use it
for stuff that we
don't expect them to use it for.
The big trend lately for us
has been in the enterprise.
A lot of business apps
are being built now.
The larger corporations
that are out there invested
all this money and all
this infrastructure
in the web and then
suddenly everyone's
showing up with iPhones.
And they've got a whole bunch
of Java programmers in the back
there, slaving away
on SQL and they
don't want to learn Objective
C. And they see Swift,
and they're like, OK, maybe
that's going to be OK.
Except for, it only works on
iOS8 and it won't work on iOS9.
So Swift is probably
not something
you want to invest in
if you're an enterprise.
So they're looking to the
web technologies as a way
to solve this.
So that seems to be the place
that we're the most popularity.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You're doing
similar things on BlackBerry,
taking the web stuff and
app-ifying onto that platform.
Are you seeing the
same kind of trends?
ELI FIDLER: Absolutely.
I mean, we have our
WebWorks platform,
which is essentially a
wrapper around Cordova.
And a huge, huge number of apps
for all BlackBerry platforms
are written using
this technology.
I think it's compelling
for application developers
because lots of people
have web skills.
And you can argue semantics
about what is the web,
and how is an app the
web or not the web.
But even if it's not
online in a browser,
people know HTML and
JavaScript and CSS,
and those technologies,
independent
of a lot of the other
problems that we've
talked about have won
in a lot of cases.
Even apps that we consider
native often have,
most of the app, or at least
a huge percentage of the app
is a web view.
BRIAN LEROUX: App stores.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is that why--
because you mentioned before
that people are building
PhoneGap style things for stuff
they probably shouldn't.
Is app stores why?
BRIAN LEROUX: I shouldn't
of said that, but--
[LAUGHTER]
I can't that one back now.
So like, for example, one of
the big ones we see is games.
We see a lot of people
building games using web tech.
And I guess when you're a young
programmer, when you're new
or you're amateur and you
want to get into software
development, one of the things
that becomes really exciting
is games.
And so we've been
saying for years,
don't build a game on PhoneGap,
that's a terrible idea.
You need delay, and have high
intensive graphics and stuff.
But it terms in mobile
that you don't actually
need high intensive
graphics and stuff.
Like Sudoku type games,
like little card games,
really simple 2D platformers.
And for that type of thing the
web is actually really good at
and it's getting better.
So that's the type of
thing where we're like,
don't use PhoneGap for that.
But people do anyways.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Dominic [INAUDIBLE]
has a point about that?
DOMINIC: Yeah, I
guess I'm just not
as interested in
using HTML and CSS,
and so on, just as a
programming language.
There's all these technologies.
You can use C Sharp and you
can use all these things
that compile to whatever's
native on the platform
or get baked in.
What I'm most interested
in is how do we get it
so I don't have to
go through Apple
and submit to their app store
and go through their review
process?
Because I don't want to just
use the web technologies,
I want to get all the
benefits of the web.
BRIAN LEROUX: There's an
answer that I can give you
when I'm not being recorded.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT ANDREWS: So right
now, your only choice
is to add to home screen, right?
You can build a single page app
or even a not to single page
app if you had hijacking
links and doing
horrible things like that.
And that's your only choice.
I think the spec,
the manifest spec
will hopefully improve that.
MARCOS CACERES: So
yeah, the manifest spec
is attempting to address that.
So it's trying to-- those
things that I mentioned before,
that list of things
that we need-- it's
trying to address those things.
But again, it requires
everybody to get on board.
If we can't get all the
browser vendors on board,
then it's like--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
who is on board then?
Chrome, Opera, Mozilla?
MARCOS CACERES:
Opera not explicitly
but they may get it
straight from Blink.
Who knows about Apple.
Microsoft has kind of said,
yeah, we're kind of interested.
It looks kind of cool.
But they haven't
committed to anything.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So can
we get a microphone
to-- Matthew
Hoffman, do you want
to raise your hand
where ever you are.
You're over there.
And Andrew, I don't have a
screen with that on here.
So it's kind of difficult for
me to see who's in the queue.
I don't know if that solvable.
If not, don't worry about it.
MATTHEW HOFFMAN: So I think
one of the problems of web apps
on mobile is that they cannot
actually integrate fully with
the native UI that the
mobile platforms provide.
So it's two islands really, and
you can call in some features,
but you cannot show anything
coming from native inside
your web app island.
MARCOS CACERES:
What do you mean?
Sorry.
What do you mean in particular?
MATTHEW HOFFMAN: Any contents.
For example, video
produced from native.
And possibly if you have UI
elements that you want to make
your web app feel more native,
you cannot do that either.
So you can leverage
sensors and all that,
but you cannot build something
that looks and feels native
in the web.
MARCOS CACERES: So can
I bounce to Brian here.
Because for PhoneGap, you're
targeting cross platform.
And I would have imagined
that if you're actually
building an app you want
it to have, more or less,
its own look and feel.
Of course leverage what
you can from the OS,
but across the board?
BRIAN LEROUX: The
first six months
of PhoneGap's life we definitely
experimented with plug-ins,
which would abstract
out user interfaces.
So that you could do things
like invoke a tab bar.
Those metaphors
got really leaky.
And they broke down super fast.
And you probably have
seen that if you've
used any kind of
compiled to solutions.
So a tab bar on iOS isn't the
same as a tab bar on Android.
[INAUDIBLE] on iOS is
usually on the bottom.
And sometimes the iOS one
has bevels and embosses.
Not anymore but it used to.
And so then you'd end up
having to kind of reinvent
CSS for this damn
tab bar and you
don't want to do that either
because there's already CSS.
And so the web
has sort of shown,
and there's lots of
projects out that
demonstrate that you can
build native like interfaces.
And I say native-like, I
won't say a native interfaces.
So like Ionic, Polymer
with material design
is actually looking
really good on Android.
Maybe not so much on iOS8 yet,
but soon it will, I'm sure.
So I don't think it's
actually worth pursuing.
We could waste our
time trying to paint
over Android's UI and
iOS' UI and create
some kind of universal UI
that everybody opts into it
and loves and it native.
Or we can just do
the stuff ourselves
with the web primitives.
And I think the extensible web
manifesto type discussion later
will touch into that a lot more.
We need these lower
level paint kind ideas
so that we can build these
properties and interfaces.
I think native
interfaces themselves,
the abstractions
are just too leaky.
If you want to build an iOS app
and have it be native, pick up
a book on Objective C.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I know some of
the custom layout stuff, that's
going to come up in the
[INAUDIBLE] panel as well.
Can we get Dominic a
microphone and we'll
wrap up this question?
DOMINIC: Yeah I just wanted
to share an interesting point
that we ran into on
the Polymer team.
When the material
design stuff came out,
we were seeing articles
where it's like,
is the paper element,
the custom element close
to the Android version?
As if the Android
version was canonical.
But really, the
team was asking, why
does everybody think the
Android version is canonical?
It might as well
just be the case
that the version we're putting
out for the web is canonical
and you should be
comparing to that.
So I kind of agree that
maybe it doesn't matter,
but also, it's like, the web
is a first class programming
platform for all
these things too,
so I thought that
was interesting.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
That kind of leads
nicely into the next question.
Or certainly in
terms of maybe not
taking Android's lead on things.
So this question's
from Andrew Betts,
I don't you've heard of him.
He says, "the web model of
granular on-demand user consent
is the only sensible way
of doing app permissions.
Why do app packaging
systems rush
to destroy that model
in favor of the broken
up front permissions list?
And I have a lot of
sympathy for this,
because I know in the
Chrome web install,
when TweetDeck's
there and there were
a series of user
reviews saying, I
don't trust this because
when I go to install it,
it asks to be able to
tweet on my behalf.
I don't want it to do that.
That sounds crazy.
But people didn't
realize that when
you type in a box on
TweetDeck and you hit tweet,
TweetDeck is tweeting on your
behalf, that's what it's doing.
And it asks for permission at
that point it would make sense.
So Chris, Google uses
this up front model
for Chrome apps in Android.
Why do we keep getting it wrong?
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WILSON: I think that
was a decision you made.
No, I mean, I think the reason
why we keep doing this--
and I won't say it's
wrong, necessarily.
The reason why we keep doing
is it's seductively easy.
You just pop something
up-- yeah 90% of the users
may not actually read it.
99.999% of the users may not
read it, but they click OK.
And then from the
app's perspective
they get to do whatever
they needed to do.
They get to do
whatever they want.
This is not really good.
I'm not saying this is
the right thing to do.
But I think that we are
trying to do this better.
The flow chart that Marcos
put up on the screen earlier
is a smarter way of thinking
about how you should
be doing some of
these permissions.
And I think for web applications
we will have to do much better.
Because I started reading
some of those things
on my native apps and I stopped
installing a bunch of apps,
because they wanted
to do crazy stuff.
And particularly
on iOS, you know,
they started separating
these out where you can,
not get notifications,
for example.
And while the little
notifications-- I am just
obsessive enough with the
little numbers on every icon
drive me batty.
Like I can't stand
having numbers popping up
all the time.
So I just disable every
application, even the ones
that I might care
about because of that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And we do.
Google Plus as well, right?
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
Yes, yes.
MATT ANDREWS: Would
it be too much to ask
to have both systems?
So that apps that clearly
needed loads of permissions
could ask for them up,
but ones like TweetDeck,
maybe you'd only need to
ask for the TweetDeck one
when you actually wanted to--
CHRIS WILSON: But see that's
kind of the wrong model
because apps that need loads
of permissions-- every app is
going to say I need
loads of permissions.
MATT ANDREWS: But hopefully
they would care about their uses
and their users would complain.
And they would change that.
CHRIS WILSON: You're
debating about people
caring about things.
MARCOS CACERES: I
think experience
shows that that is
not how it works.
Like if you give
people that foot gun,
basically they're
going to use it.
CHRIS WILSON: Absolutely.
ELI FIDLER: Users
don't really complain
about upfront
permission dialogs.
They complain a lot when
their flow is interrupted.
CHRIS WILSON: They do.
I think though, that
the smart bit here
is, we need to not just
say, every time you need
a permission, pop
a new dialogue.
An app developer
needs to intelligently
say, wait, I need
to be able to do x.
And I can now explain
to them user in a way
that they're going to
understand at that moment, why
I need to do that.
Like TweetDeck, for example.
Instead of just
having, TweetDeck
wants to be able to
tweet on your behalf,
it should be able
to say, hey, we
need to post to Twitter when
you type stuff into the box.
Like, just click OK and
we know we can do that.
Or hopefully not click OK for
every permission, but something
where they can explain why
they need that ability.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Can we
get a microphone to Jonas?
Put your hand up.
I think you hit the
nail on the head when
you made the comparison
to terms and conditions,
because that's a model
that we know doesn't work.
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But we
still do it to users.
CHRIS WILSON: Yes.
Exactly like the ULA.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well that's
like the source code of the law.
CHRIS WILSON: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And we
still present that to users.
I kind of wish that if we
detected a liar visiting
one of our sites, we should just
serve up the raw source code.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: If they expect
us to read their source code
they should read ours.
CHRIS WILSON: We can
make that happen.
We can make that happen.
JONAS: Yeah, so, a
couple of comments.
First of all people are talking
about the web versus packaged
apps and how packaged
apps have these properties
from security permission
prompts and so on.
And actually we don't
have to tie packaged apps
to these prompts.
In Firefox OS we use exactly the
same security model as the web.
First of all, to try to have
as few prompts as possible.
Like design API so
that you can do stuff
without actually
impacting security.
But then for APIs,
like geolocation,
where we do want to prompt the
user-- even for packaged apps--
we just follow the
normal web model
and we ask for
permission in context.
And so if there's a
TweetDeck app that
needs to do some
special stuff then
it can ask that at the time
when it needs to do it.
And what we've found
is that there's
two things are important.
It's very important
for applications.
The context of asking at
the time when you do it
helps users to understand
why this happens.
But also enabling
applications to describe,
why do I need to do this.
Because many times this
can sort of look shocking
that when you actually get a
chance to talk to the user,
like, why do you need to read
my contact list, or why do
you need to--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what
kind of things Firefox
OS us upfront permissions for?
JONAS: We don't use
up front permissions
for anything at all.
So Firefox makes a distinction
between security questions
and privacy questions.
And what we've decided is that,
generally speaking, asking
user security questions
is a bad idea.
Because most people-- it's
hard to relate to them
and to understand what
they're actually about.
So asking the uses,
like, do you want
this app to have
TCP socket access?
That means nothing to people.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
leads into something
that was a very similar question
that was by Connell saying,
yeah, are we asking too many
technical questions of users
and then blaming them for
picking the wrong answer?
For things like
sockets, or do you
want this to access something.
We've trained people
to just click OK.
So even the web
model, are we starting
to break that with these
too technical decisions.
Also can we get a
microphone to Adam Singer.
If you-- raise your hand.
ADAM SINGER: Hi.
I was little bit bugged there,
I don't work for Google.
So talking about single page
applications-- so routing
is like a fundamental component
of single page applications.
So what could the web
platform do better?
So it's more native
experience for routing?
Why should we depend
on a framework
to handle our routing
for us, which then makes
us buy into a framework
just to even develop a spot?
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
I've actually done
routing without a
framework before.
In fact, you can--
ADAM SINGER: Is it fun?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: A request
goes to the server
and it works, right?
Right?
The web, yay?
MARCOS CACERES: There's
a missing-- the missing
bit is, I think, pre-loading.
And pre-loading and--
for me personally, it's
like pre-loading the page
that you're potentially
going to navigate to and
transitioning to that page.
And I think until we have those
things, until we can smoothly
go from one page to another--
BRIAN LEROUX: IE5
used to have that.
MARCOS CACERES: And IE5--
BRIAN LEROUX: It
probably still does.
Remember those
awesome transitions?
MARCOS CACERES: Yeah.
And I think we need to
bring that-- I don't think
we need to bring
that back but I think
we need to look at that again.
And I think the IE team-- you
worked there at that time?
CHRIS WILSON: I have no comment.
[LAUGHTER]
MARCOS CACERES: Because
it wasn't-- like,
it was a cool feature.
CHRIS WILSON: Yes, it was.
MARCOS CACERES: And it
was an interesting feature
and I think we might need to
actually look at that again.
CHRIS WILSON: Yep.
MARCOS CACERES: And
I know, like-- is
Ilya Grigorik around somewhere?
Maybe not here yet.
Oh, he's over there.
So I know Ilya is working on
the pre-render render spec.
You know they bring
it to pre-render page
and then you quickly navigate
to it and it's instantaneous.
So that may help with
the whole routing thing.
So you don't need single
page apps so much.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Can
we get a microphone
to Alex Russell,
wherever he's hiding?
Oh, he's over there.
So what do you think transitions
are going to give us then?
What does that break?
MARCOS CACERES: Well then
you can slide in a page.
Slide it in from the left side,
slide it in from the right.
BRIAN LEROUX: But state gets
blown away in the process, so.
MARCOS CACERES: Maybe.
But, yeah, I don't know.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRIAN LEROUX: You could keep
all your logic and index DB
and load it when the page--
[LAUGHTER]
MARCOS CACERES: Yeah, why not?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And answer
that starts index DB
is the wrong answer.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN LEROUX: Right,
local storage.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX RUSSELL: Hi, just
a couple of comments.
The first is that there is
work, Marcos, to your point,
happening in Chromium
right now about something
called navigation transitions.
Which bring HTML transition
filters of your back,
but for specific
elements that pages
want to send to other pages
to transition through.
So that code-- patches
are landing now.
So that's not obviously
a standard yet,
but it's something
that we're working on.
Similarly, patches
have just landed
in Chromium for
manifest support.
And the add to desktop widget
for your Chrome for Android
is going to take
advantage of those soon.
So that's a hopeful step
in then next direction.
And I think to
the routing point,
it's a very interesting one.
I'm hopeful-- again, I'm
one of the people who
bang on about service workers,
because I'm working on it.
I'm hopeful that we can offload,
in many cases, a lot of that
to the client side without
changing the model of how
a single page is constructed.
Single page applications are
muddled because you often
wind up having to rebuild
URL structure afterwards.
And what you sort of want is
navigations to be hung off
of URLs.
But then to end up at
the next page with it
a URL and a good UI.
Navigation transitions
plus service workers
should hopefully give you
a lot of responsiveness
without having to
go to the network
and flash white in
front of the user.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Matt, when you
were building the FT stuff,
how were you handling routing.
Were you using just
normal web requests?
Or were you kind
of hijacking that?
MATT ANDREWS: So
yeah, with the web
apps we've got at the moment
it is, listens to the clicks,
look in the URL in
[INAUDIBLE] counselor
and then rebuild it in the
very front end of the browser.
I've been playing
with service worker,
and with the early
things in Canary.
And you can move
all that into kind
of-- well, if the back
end's to your server
and the front end's your
website, like, the middle end.
So something that
pretends to be a server.
And that's much easier.
Although you do lose
state between each one,
you could store that state.
Index DB is not great,
but you could do that.
There's something alive
that lives longer than
that page that you could store
say in-- I not you're not
supposed source it in service
worker, but you could do it.
[LAUGHTER]
But the point is you
don't have to worry
about the other
consequences of having
that state in the front end.
Because you have the
potential for pages
to start interfering
with each other.
You have an advert
on one and that
could break something
completely unrelated.
So the nice thing
with service worker
is you get a fresh instance
of the browser page each time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I
think with that we're
going to move on to the next
question, which is actually
my favorite question that
appeared in Google Moderator.
And yes, that is this.
Angle bracket, slash text
area, close angle bracket,
image source y on
error prompt one.
I'm going to direct
this question at Brian.
[LAUGHTER]
I think that came from
little Bobby Tables.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN LEROUX: I like that
they've done this HTML5 style
without having to
quote their attributes.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a good style.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
actually from the future.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, we'll probably move on
from that to the next question.
[LAUGHTER]
So this came from Connell,
who's provided actually
a lot of the really
good questions
for many of the panels, so
you'll get bored of his name
soon. "Instead of asking for
permissions for small things,
can browsers instead
infer a level of trust
from other factors such
as usage frequency,
whether it's from bookmarked
or reputation of the domain?"
Chris, you're Google, right?
Should Google
decide which domains
get enhanced permissions
based on our ratings?
Because that sounds
like the kind of thing
the public would really love.
CHRIS WILSON: Absolutely.
[LAUGHTER]
I think users will be
as delighted with that
as they are to get ads that
are more applicable to them.
[LAUGHTER]
And I mean that completely.
No, I mean I think that
we already, in some ways,
we already do similar things.
In that if you visit
a page with HTTPS
and it asks for access to
the microphone, for example,
the next time you visit
it, we don't ask again.
We cache that, we
remember that you said OK,
and it's a secure domain.
"Secure" domain.
I do think that there are
things in that question that
make a small trickle of
sweat go down my spine.
So I won't say absolutely, we
should do all of these things.
But I do think that being
more intelligent about how
we can infer trust
from other things
that the user has
said or done, as long
as we can have a clear, secure
track back to the domain.
I think that that's
probably the right future.
But we're several
steps from there still.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So rather
than completely deciding it
based on ratings, if
something like bookmarking
was used as a signal, is that
something that sounds fair?
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
ELI FIDLER: Bookmarking
is used as a signal today.
So if you saved a
home screen on iOS
and then launch it
from the home screen,
it can control mostly at
every pixel of the screen.
That's not a
permission that we give
to websites in the browser.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hmm, true, true.
What kind of permissions
would make sense
to sort of auto-grant
for something
that was added to the home
screen that wouldn't surprise
a user that we've granted that?
CHRIS WILSON: I think
that's a challenge.
Because that's true, if
you add to home screen
you get a bunch of extra rights.
And I'll also say that I
think, add to home screen
is the worst thing today because
it's buried in every mobile OS
that I've seen.
And hard to find, hard to
discover for average users.
I mean, I think in
Android, you have
to click an icon that's
not at all intuitive
and then it's like, at the very
bottom on my phone, where it's
almost getting cut
off the screen.
Which seems really bizarre for
something that I want to do.
And as a user it's
not clear that when
I click that I'm giving
additional rights.
Like it means
something other than
stick an icon on my
home screen somewhere.
And that bit, I'm a
little worried about.
How we explain that to users.
That it's not install, it's not
this gigantic Android-esque,
here are all the permissions
that you're magically
getting now.
Are you sure you're OK with
that, good, kind of thing.
But it does also
somehow indicate
to the user in an obvious way--
MARCOS CACERES: But
this is like where
Adrian's diagram
comes into play.
Because adding to home
screen and getting
all the pixels is
a minor annoyance.
CHRIS WILSON: It is, yes.
MARCOS CACERES:
So there is that.
So maybe there shouldn't
be a permission for that?
So again, it's trying to
find that balance and--
BRIAN LEROUX: I think
the biggest problem
we've got right
now is that we've
spent seven years
teaching people
to install apps
from the app store.
And we've spent seven years of
people thinking that discovery
happens by going to Play
or going to an app store.
And there's no-- I
guess the closest
thing we have right
now is like, Google
would be the app
store for the web.
But there's no way for us
to say, OK, this is a thing,
and this thing's going
to be on your device.
And it's going to do
things that maybe you
wouldn't want it
to do necessarily.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Can we get a
microphone to Guy, by the way.
CHRIS WILSON: We've also spent
more than 20 years teaching
people that everything on
the web is totally safe.
And don't worry about it.
[LAUGHTER]
And now we're-- as Jake said
at the beginning, now there's--
BRIAN LEROUX: As long as there's
a little lock, it's all good.
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
Even without the lock, you
can't do anything dangerous.
GUY: I just wanted to
point out that there
might be a difference between
the permissions of what
we're talking about.
So sometimes there are security
and privacy permissions.
And also kind of
makes wet trickle down
my spine to think that
Google would determine
to give my location
away, or something
like that based on usage.
On the other hand,
things like resources,
quota for local storage--
if everybody started
using local storage of the
new service worker quota,
you know, there would be
a problem for the agents.
You know, when does the
machine blow up and run out
of the space.
Maybe things around usability
or accessibility, what gets
loaded up first and
things like that.
So we might want
to split-- I guess
to me, for certain types of
permissions we prompt for today
that are more around
usage and resources,
it makes sense that
the browser would infer
for privacy and
security reasons.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Marcos,
what kind of stuff
does Firefox OS
give you by default
if you're an installed app?
Is there anything in particular?
MARCOS CACERES:
So I'll be honest,
I don't know too much
about Firefox OS,
because I mostly
focus on the web.
But we could ask Jonas, because
Jonas is like-- you know.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I guess
a question I'd ask
is how to you handle
things like disk space?
Is that something that you
give the user for free?
JONAS: Yeah, so our
design policy has been,
once the user
installs something you
get to use resources
as much as you want.
You get unlimited
access to resources.
So that's things like CPU
running in the background, band
wave, and storing stuff to disk.
And then you also get
to annoy the user.
So things like,
notifications will
let you do without any prompts.
And the idea has
been that we give you
the users all of these--
or we give applications
all these things, but then
we give tools to the users
so can dial it down
if they want to.
So users can say, this
is very annoying app,
I'm going to turn off
notifications for it,
or just uninstall it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So should
we do the same on the web?
Add to home screens?
Same style permissions?
MARCOS CACERES: I
mean, I would say yes.
Like if you're going to
do that then integrate it
into the system as
much as possible.
CHRIS WILSON: But it--
BRIAN LEROUX: Firefox also has
three layers of apps though.
There's implicit
on board blessed
apps that get full
system access,
then there's installed
apps from the wild,
and they don't get
full system access.
Isn't that the case currently?
Like there's two layers?
MARCOS CACERES: Hosted
apps, certified, and--
BRIAN LEROUX: Yeah.
JONAS: We have three levels.
We have the certified
apps that are built-in.
We have privileged apps which
have to be signed and reviewed
by the Mozilla marketplace.
And then we have
normal web apps.
BRIAN LEROUX: So that's the same
as-- well it's not the same,
but it's similar to
Apple's security model.
There's a curation
process, which
is-- I think this is the thing
that the web community is
like most adverse to.
You know, we don't like
the idea that there's
a central place where
someone gets to curate,
effectively censor, what
other people get to see.
And at the same time, we
don't want My Little Pony apps
turning into the gambling,
porno app overnight.
CHRIS WILSON: Well even more
than My Little Pony apps,
which my daughter's
would love, you
need the ability to have
some kind of insight
into where your
disk space is going.
Like particularly when we're
talking about mobile devices.
That storage is still a
somewhat limited quantity.
And I don't want
every application
to think, yeah, it's
totally cool to dump
100 gigabytes of
stuff onto my device.
Because it may not be,
but at the same time
there are certainly
applications that I
want to be able to store
100 gigabytes of game data
or whatever, and keep it there.
And don't just arbitrarily
dump it out of cache
because you need some.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We've
got the Cordova API
and Mozilla's not too
keen on that right?
MARCOS CACERES:
Not that I know of.
But the thing is that
you can handle that thing
in different ways, right?
There are other
signals we can use.
The way you don't need
to annoy the user.
You can annoy the user if you
want, but you don't have to.
Then there are
other places where
you can go within the
device to actually see
which app is actually
using up how much space.
Which is what happens
in Firefox OS.
And so there are various ways
to manage it that don't actually
have to have an
API bound to them.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So Alex do
you have something to say?
You're on that screen,
but not that screen.
So do you have something to say?
ALEX RUSSELL: Again, two things.
So the first is that, I think,
between Marcos and Jonas
we've identified a really
interesting split between, sort
of the web-centric view of what
it means to have a permission,
sort of ambulantly
granted, and then
sort of the trust
level view of what
it means to have a
permission granted.
And I think, even inside
of one organization,
you see multiple
opinions expressed.
And I think one of the things
that we're trying to do now,
in the design of new web
APIs is to make sure--
and vendors, even inside
the same organization,
different vendors and even
inside the same organization
can express different
policies without having
to agree on different APIs.
So one of things
that I think people
get very bound up
in is exactly what
the UI for a particular
policy is going to be.
But if we make these requests
for permission asynchronous,
we make it the
developer's problem,
on some level to deal with.
And I think that's
one of the big ways
out that we can evolve through.
Because we don't
have agreement yet.
And getting agreement is going
to require experimentation.
The second side of
this is that it's
one thing for Google to sort
of automatically intuit who
should have what permissions.
And I think that sounds very
scary to everyone including me.
But we don't necessarily
feel bad about Google
running the safe
browsing system.
And so the idea that we're going
to be able to hit Control Z
and keep users safe once we
acquire some knowledge of abuse
is very different to the idea
that we're going to mediate
upfront permissions,
outside of the user's intent
and outside the user-presented
model of what they think
is going to happen when they
decide to keep or install
a particular thing, or agree
to a particular pop up.
So it's good, and we
surface a bunch of the UI
for mediating these permissions
once they're granted.
But I think we need to
keep in mind that it's
more important to be able
to hit Control Z then
to mediate the upfront thing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So Chris Messiner,
are you-- oh you got a
microphone, go for it.
CHRIS MESSINER: Test.
OK.
So you guys are sort of
taking a look at this
from the current
state of technology
but we're on the cusp
of user interfaces,
in particular, that don't
actually require pixels.
So whether it's a
voice activated thing
or you're in the car
and you're driving,
or there's shared
interfaces where
it's more of a collaborative,
computing experience,
where does all of
these problems go
and how do you deal with that?
What happens when there's
multiple users that
are authenticated?
And again, what happens
when you don't actually
have pixels to display with
text for a user to read?
What does that look like?
CHRIS WILSON: I that's one
of the reasons why this model
where the developer's more
in control of when they ask
the question-- when they
say to the user, hey,
I want the ability
to x because y.
I think that lets you
build applications
that have that sort of thing.
Where you don't necessarily
have a screen all the time
to look at things.
Now the question of, if
you never have a screen,
I think that becomes even harder
and then it's sort of, well,
what does that lock to?
Like, at some level do you
have to have permissions
that are read out to the user?
If it's a voice
interaction system?
Probably, unless
you've locked it
to some set of the apps upfront
that are pre-authenticated,
in which case, you're good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So with that we're
going to move onto the next
question, which comes from me.
Assuming we fix offline
and install-ability-- all
of these problems are solved.
BRIAN LEROUX: Sweet.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, great.
But how do we get people
to expect them to work?
How can a user expect
the web to work offline?
Or have these
advanced capabilities?
CHRIS WILSON: Jake,
what do thing?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
have no idea, that's
why I put the question there.
I was hoping we could
sort this out right now.
BRIAN LEROUX: I don't anybody's
figured this out, including
native apps, right?
We're still having
a lot of trouble.
You can't install
an app unless you
are online which is something
people seem to forget a lot.
And now once you've got
that app installed-- like,
even Twitter thrashers
when it's starting up.
It's like, oh, what
am I doing right now?
Am I loading new
stuff or am I showing
you stuff that you
already had here?
You have the noticeable three
second delay with Twitter.
Which is probably one of the top
used apps on everybody's phone
here.
So what's it going to look like?
I don't know.
Not that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT ANDREWS: Maybe this is
the developer's responsibility.
Maybe this is not--
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
You're a developer.
MATT ANDREWS: Well, not the
browser's responsibility,
our responsibility.
Because it's up to us to make
a good experience, firstly.
And there's no point
shouting, "it works offline,"
if, when people actually come
around to using it, it doesn't.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So how did you
handle that in the FT case?
MATT ANDREWS: Well, we
just shout about it.
You know, it's on
all of the adverts
for all of the promos for it.
I mean if you've ever visited
FT.com on your mobile device,
you get a big, irritating
thing that comes up and says,
use our app because that's
what you'd want to do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Did you find
users actually using offline?
I guess it's difficult
to do analytics on that.
MATT ANDREWS: No, we
have analytics on that.
We have analytics on that.
Basically we get, we
people are offline,
we store in local
storage and then--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, cool.
MATT ANDREWS: Taking it
back when-- yeah, yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You did do it?
MATT ANDREWS: There are some
subtle complexities with that
but, yeah, I think 20%
of traffic is offline.
Or something like that.
That's quite an old stat, so
it might be different now.
But yeah, people use it.
People complain
when we break it,
which happens sometimes too.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I know more
about the state of iOS apps
than Android apps.
Do the majority of
BlackBerry apps work offline?
Do you find that the ones are
sort of, built in the Cordova
way, are they offline capable?
Is that well
communicated to the user?
ELI FIDLER: I think a lot of
them are available offline.
Obviously app
developers don't always
do a good job about this.
Even top apps often don't
do a good job with this.
But for the Cordova
style case, there's
something fundamental
about the technology that
makes it that hard to implement
something that works offline.
In the browser, that's
a different problem.
We know that there's lots of
issues with the technology
there.
But we know that users don't
expect that [INAUDIBLE]
to work offline, even
if it could today.
If you hit the browser icon
people don't expect that.
MATT ANDREWS: But if
we did train users
to expect to use it offline,
they'd be disappointed a lot.
Because I think most
websites, no matter
how much we say it's
possible, most websites
won't bother to do it.
CHRIS WILSON: But I think
we train users today
that native apps work offline.
And I'm frequently
disappointed then as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
you've saying the Cordova
stuff doesn't work offline well?
Is that your?
ELI FIDLER: No it does.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It does.
ELI FIDLER: The technology
makes it work offline.
So then it's up to
the app developers.
BRIAN LEROUX: So
this actually keyed
on something that's been
bugging us a lot lately.
So the way Cordova works today,
we load off the file protocol.
So anything on file, colon,
slash, slash, we load it.
And then WebKit has this
awesome feature, maybe a bug,
that there's no content security
policy on file, colon, slash,
slash.
So you can load anything
from any domain,
which is kind of rad.
In iOS8-- Marcos
talked about this--
there's this new web view.
And in iOS8 we can't load off,
file, colon, slash, slash.
And it's a bug, and it's been
marked in radar as a bug.
So Cordova's not going to get
to use the new WK webview.
Or at least that's what
I think they thought,
and we thought initially.
We found that there's
a work around.
And interestingly,
we've had this work
around for awhile in
our Android world,
where we run a web
server on the phone.
I know everybody's like, what
the fuck are you talking about?
Run a web server on your phone?
It works.
And so, we can load
off a local host.
But now we're running a
full fledged web server
as a part of our
app on the client.
And that's got implications that
I totally don't understand yet.
I know Opera did it first,
if there's an Opera guy here.
But it's interesting.
And so I don't know
where this goes
but this changes the
whole offline question
all together now, because now
I'm running a fully capable web
server on the device as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It should
have just like a proxy server,
and then you could have
called it Service Worker,
and then we could
put it in a browser.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN LEROUX: Well,
Service Worker
is kind of like a web server-ish
interface on a phone too.
So we're entering
into this world
where there's web
servers everywhere.
Maybe we will have the
distributed computing
thing happen.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
OK, next question.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN LEROUX: I really
killed the conversation.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, no, it's
more the next question, not
this question.
So recently-- as comes
from Andrew Betts as well.
Thanks Andrew.
Recently Chrome experimented
with hiding the URL.
Is this another step in the
appification of the web?
Yeah, because I
wrote a blog post
about this when Chrome
has that experiment where
they were hiding the URL.
And it landed on Hacker News.
And the internet fire
hose was pointed at me,
and it was filled with fire.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a fun blog post to look at.
So Chris, why does Google
hate the web so much?
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't like everybody
picking on you
but I didn't want to show bias.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WILSON: I think
you've succeeded
in not showing
pro-Google bias in this.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So, but,
Brian, like the PhoneGap apps,
they don't--
BRIAN LEROUX: We don't
show half the URLs.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So URLs,
they're pointless right?
They're dead?
You hate URL's as well?
BRIAN LEROUX: There's
problems with URLs.
I can argue that.
If you play with
Opera's coast browser--
I don't know why I'm
giving Opera so many props,
but whatever, they're good.
MARCOS CACERES:
They do good work.
BRIAN LEROUX: They do good work.
So Opera's coast
browser has no URL
and it's surprisingly nice to
navigate and play around with.
And I totally recommend
checking it out.
The URL is not going away.
So that thing will
be there for awhile.
Whether or not we have
to show that to a user
is fully up for debate,
and it should be.
Just because a URL is a great
idea, doesn't mean the users
have to know that it's there.
That's my belief on it,
but that's obviously
firehouse material, so.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Matt,
you dealt with the web.
So was the URL useful
to you still, in an app?
A web app?
MATT ANDREWS: From a technical
point of view it's useful.
I just want to say that no
one complained-- well no one
I saw complained
when Safari did this.
It seems unfortunate that Chrome
get the front on the anger.
CHRIS WILSON: It
does, doesn't it?
Really does.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT ANDREWS: But yeah,
we rely on the URL.
[LAUGHTER]
Make Service Worker,
have 'em quickly.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WILSON: Afterwards.
You don't do it in
front of people.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I've been
getting it all wrong.
So with the BlackBerry, you guys
hide the URL as well, right?
ELI FIDLER: We hide the URL
for sites that have SSL certs
that we are very happy about.
So if you have an ED cert
that we're happy about,
we show you the issuer name.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
That makes sense.
ELI FIDLER: So the
organization name.
So, like, if you go
to Bank of America,
you see Bank of America in
green with the lock icon.
BRIAN LEROUX: I've never
been to a bank's website
where I could read
the URL anyways.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like,
j-session-id, whatever.
CHRIS WILSON: But see that's it.
I think that in response
to what you were saying,
you were saying you don't
think URLs are going away
anytime soon.
I don't think they're
ever going away on the web
because I feel that's
fundamental to what the web is.
It's like, linkable URLs.
But at the same time, the idea
that you can sanely read a URL,
that time is gone.
That time's been gone
for a decade or more
at this point at least.
And it is all junk in there
and you shouldn't read it,
but it's still an identifier,
it's still something
that-- I feel like in how I
internalized the UI of a web
application, that's
just a little marker
and it's totally opaque.
It's a token identifier.
It's a button that
I want to press,
or something, to go back to it.
But it's not actually
something I really need to see.
BRIAN LEROUX: We keep
getting attracted
to this idea of human readable.
Remember when people said
XML is human readable?
People used to say that.
And then they started saying,
no, that's not human readable,
JSON is.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WILSON: You didn't
sit down last night
with a big tome of XML
and just read it for fun?
BRIAN LEROUX: Just
paging through it.
God, this is beautiful.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Andrew's holding
a microphone, looking eager.
ANDREW BETTS: So one of
the biggest arguments
for the hiding of the URL
is the phishing thing.
You know, that you want to
avoid users being phished
by hiding the bit
of the URL that's
least important in identifying
that the site is safe.
And I think one of
the biggest problems
with that is that it
doesn't actually work.
Because you have a phone
that is small enough
that it can only display
part of the host name.
So what you've got
to do is register
an evil dot com--
and evil dot come
which has a subdomain
that looks legit
and that has the same
prefix as the one
that you were going
to log into anyway.
So, I guess I don't
buy it, because I just
don't see that the
benefit actually exists.
CHRIS WILSON: I mean, this
is kind of what I was saying.
It's like I need to know that
that token is mostly right.
Like if I'm going to
my bank's website,
if I know that it says HTTPS
colon, wack, wack, www,
dot Bank of America dot
com, and it's all green,
and it's got the Bank of America
cert on it and everything,
it's likely OK.
But if I don't
see the URL today,
how do I know that's
where it's going?
How do I know it's not going to
evil dot-- or Bank of America
dot, blah, blah, blah,
dot evil dot com?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Can I
get Charles a microphone?
Where are you?
Hand up?
CHARLES: Hey.
Oh, wow, that's very loud.
So we've been talking a
little bit about permissions,
about installable.
I know that we've got a question
coming about fragmentation,
what happens if we start doing
application installation, how
that potentially
fragments the web.
OK.
No, that's on me.
So I'm thinking about
hiding URL here.
What happens if we look at
browser vendors as app stores?
And is that a future
that is scary to us?
Having them sort of be trusted
authority on permissions?
On all of those
things that occur
when we install an application.
If that happens in the future,
is that scary or is that good?
BRIAN LEROUX: It's happening.
I mean it's already--
CHRIS WILSON: --Chrome Web Store
has kind of got, for example.
But I'm not sure that's the
model that we really want.
I mean I work on a
browser, I've worked
on other browsers in the past
and I still like the fact
that they're somewhat
interchangeable.
Right?
I don't actually have a boatload
of Chrome Web apps installed
on my machines because I
like the fact that I can use
the web, and I can use
something that's like an app,
but I don't have to
install something
that doesn't work
if I go to my iPad
and I don't have all
of that browser there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
We also, as people
who work on browsers
and developers,
Are we all agreed to
the open web thing?
This idea of vendors
controlling which
things appear in an app store.
We're all committed to
never doing-- or trying
to rid the world of that, yeah?
BRIAN LEROUX: I'm warming to it.
And not to the current model.
So I don't think,
for example, there
should be these
singular app stores.
But I'm warming to
the idea that there
should be many app stores.
Like Mozilla experimented
with the idea of federating--
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah, absolutely.
Like, many app stores,
I could get behind.
Although it becomes
challenging to secure that.
BRIAN LEROUX: It's terrible
that, for example, I
trust Steam.
I trust 'em.
They have games, right?
And I know what kind of
permissions those games need.
They need full screen and
they need audio, whatever.
And so I would totally
trust a Steam app store
on any of my devices.
And I think that's kind of
direction we're going now.
Can we standardize,
federate, and open
that part up is
the real question.
And then what does
become of the web then?
I think the web community
is afraid of app stores,
rightfully, because they're
currently curation points that
are centralized and
dangerous and kind of weird,
because your have
Steve Jobs deciding
what's appropriate content.
And he's not alive anymore,
so how's that possible?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
with that we are out
of time for the
session, but we'll
be able to continue discussions
in the breakout sessions later.
I'd like to thank
all the panelists.
It's been scary and interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]